and here it is the last lap in the
season-long race for the trophy millions
of years from around the world are
tuning in for the biggest final in club
football the Champions League final
Marco Verratti starts alongside at viaje
Bo in the center of the park and the
main striker today is Edinson Cavani the
Uruguayan radio versus Neymar
marquinhos get lost Elsa
give it away
Walker
and sterling has it
LeMay Royce on a good not to work too
hard to say that before
and I can remember watching PSG when
they didn't have the attached glamour
that as part of the Panda Clara
there's a slide roll pass and it all
counts for not
[Applause]
dani alves mythix bodies forward and the
break looks on the dark oak chris and
accurate its with Mende autumn nd has it
regaining possession for his son just a
bit too high were that powerful Everett
he just leaned back Derrick Powell was
there but not the direction
company and now Kevin de Bruyne er
Walker now we have the sixth sense to
know what to do and win it back
Shivani with a slide rule pass Bobby in
the way and the psg corner
that's a dink corner he was being very
closely marks but the header not on the
target
no just off target and the thing is the
defender did his job and he just
couldn't quite get enough of his head on
it Bernadine yeah
agüero sterling has it ball lost
Neymar
traffic go man
gonna give in to PSG
[Applause]
and now the delivery splendid sir from
the keeper danger averted yeah he didn't
have long to react to that but you have
to praise his reflexes there
[Applause]
marquinhos mrs. Tiago Silva
Xavier
[Applause]
carrying a genuine threat here David
Silva the danger now
and so it is psg have reached the
promised land of the UEFA Champions
League final the question now is Li can
they win it well this is where they want
to be they want to be at the big boys
table eating dinner there their corn eat
[Applause]
the SG on the move with purpose what can
they do and Neymar the girl ban for
panty says you're mad the first one of
this Champions League final well they've
got the noses in front can they stay
there now the other team are playing
catch-up well just look at this they all
back often and he takes the advantage he
goes through
three in the end is a wonderful solo
gone
[Applause]
and back in business advantage PSG
and now Kevin de Bruyne er autumn nd has
a damaged silver
sterling given away by City
[Applause]
miss Elsa
it's an excellent attack from VSG but
will there be an end product
and now Kevin de Bruyne
Senay
the blinds are now
[Applause]
Valachi the cell so that means some
Giovanni now
welcome
ass is a free kick for coming
the electronic board has been held aloft
two additional minutes here Cavani
immaculate me place by kabbani
incisive past remember pay and
ultimately up a cul-de-sac beautifully
taken gold by Marco Verratti
let's see that one again it's all about
the contact was everything right he's
not bothered where the goal is he knows
where it is he gets a beautiful stripe
on it subtly different vantage point in
terms of the goal that was score
[Applause]
the second Gulf Oldham here
if I am
and that is that for the first half in
this Champions League final and my
goodness Li did we think it would be so
lopsided 45 minutes separating these two
sides from glory the second half of the
Champions League final begins
Bharati
[Applause]
is he going to punish them here
well sir
routinely
Ronaldinho with it Walker complainer now
whatever way you slice it a good night's
work for this fellow so far plea well
Derek is that a storm er hasn't he
scored a goal he certainly troubled all
the defenders around there as well I
think there's more to come in the second
half and the shot decidedly lacking
accuracy well he had other options as
well but he chose to shoot
Thiago Silva
let's just name our
crabby Oh now cool Sawa well that's a
really good-looking patty Sasha with
tackling like that the onus is on the
referee to take action potentially
Walker's illegal tackle and a yellow
card yeah he's got to be careful now
yellow card dangerous
[Applause]
and Manchester City will go to their
bench
[Applause]
[Applause]
Neymar has a go here the free-kick from
distance just off target well I wasn't
expecting that I'm pretty sure the goal
keep it wasn't as well it was close
[Applause]
company
[Applause]
Senay
every goalkeeper would expect to a catch
that one
[Applause]
I'm trying to get right into his face
they've given it away
[Applause]
fernandinho
sunny is with David Silva and mrs. sunny
and then for the real chance only the
King Rosa Beach Kevin de Bruyne with the
go
[Applause]
[Music]
well as we see there'll be an inquest
between keeper and defenders you'll be
saying where were you and they'll be
saying why didn't you catch it the girl
again albeit from a different angle
[Applause]
well ii wanna tease here Shivani Neymar
and dispossessed
barnardine yo with it so 20 minutes to
go the taco completely missed time and
you would expect a booking under the
circumstances
[Applause]
for following that tackle he's got to go
into the book
yeah he's missed time more than anything
they're just missed time these tackle
[Applause]
not too fussy and clear it will be a
pati soshim a free-kick
[Applause]
gizmo's Elsa
[Applause]
space afforded DSG
running with the ball confidently had a
play for a paddy soshim are throwing we
have elected to go to the bench at this
stage of the game
[Applause]
but bay with it
and whipped into the box
[Applause]
my race
he's being a bit unlucky walkin out
the referee has decided to give the
free-kick decision the way of city
they will now make use of the
substitutes bench
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well they had a decent reading of that
balling
Tozawa and passing by the Velvet Touch
leymah looking confident with the ball
at his feet
they ready to pounce just wanted to get
it out of there
inside the final five minutes now
and plenty of scope to be creative in
that white position that's a fairly easy
say for any keeper to make
[Music]
[Applause]
like slow now
I mean Santa Vani now thank goodness he
was right on top of the situation to get
the ball back for his team and the
referee is going to add on three minutes
[Applause]
trailing as they are not likely to get
too many opportunities late in this game
well the keeper is happy the bar was
there the world after that piece of
woodwork
per se
shines through
PSG huh
the Champions League
[Applause]
look down at the celebrations that
really
[Applause]
the other players but it's the
celebration time now all that sacrifice
and commitment desire
to win a trophy and if one the biggest
one absolutely brilliant
this is what Patti says your man have
been targeting for a good
it's official now
PSG huh based in Europe
how many times to get
take that
[Applause]
he puts his hand on this famous trophy
the cup with the big ears as they
sometimes call it and it's the property
now
[Applause]
psg while have been celebrating long
into the night with their friends and
family quite rightly so
of the late night Tara comes you're a
fantastic feeling for all concerns as
they drink it
but the big ears as its affectionately
known
[Applause]
[Music]
get a chance to take it a little bit
closer to those stands let them enjoy
the experience with you and the families
are up there in the stands as well a
brilliant occasion
they took fire as
on the pitch necessary
now comes from
my mom always told me to get on the
front row
she told you well me
[Music]
the Champions League Victor's for 2019
[Applause]